alors oui la force alors je te voir
prendre la voie et la peau des autres on
a fini par oublier qu'il y avait un vrai
le cocq sida soit aussi ça t'arrive qui
d'ailleurs s'appelle pas du tout le coq
mais le coc pierre oui mais on m'a
appelé quand même déjà le corps policier
donc j'ai gardé le pseudo est la
première voiture a su faire c'est de
gaulle j'ai peut-être plus conscience
des mutations avec avec de gaulle mais
j'en ai fait monsieur lamarre fait avant
sans savoir que ce sont des imitations
je visais ma source dans les
discothèques de mai seraient donc
c'était c'était bécaud c'était court et
aujourd'hui tu peux en faire combien et
aujourd'hui j'en fais une centaine de
voix par les gens nés en stock
certainement un peu plus mais de celles
qui se pratique qu'on reconnaît encore
hélas ans et puis autant de chanter
sébastien loeb fait plus mais gigamic
pas encore les way est ce que leur
perfection est ce qu'ils ne voient
justement est-ce qu'à une boîte
justement qu'il fait mieux que
l'original de quelques fois j'ai entendu
dire des victimes
attention parce que tu chantes trop bien
je vais avoir du mal à timité quelqu'un
qui sait peut-être d'immensité pierre
perret disait le champagne parce que
t'es trop juste mais toi qui s'est
imiter c'est pas que je sois moi-même
déjà mais aujourd'hui tu fais quand même
beaucoup plus de gars là que les gens
qui imitent souvent et c'est à dire que
c'est la solution de facilité dont on
est sûr d'en avoir pour tous les goûts
soutenir l'imitateur il ya vingt stars
sur flamme quoi ouais donc c'est bon
marché pour les paquets fall c'est un
type le brame pour toi serait le rub sur
la seule chose qui pouvait m'arriver
l'extinction de voix jamais arrivé ici
il préfère morose et où il avait alors
également un décodeur ce soir là tu pas
que ça se sache limité que françois
mauriac oublié et jugement l'a oublié
oui et ce qui t'arrive l'idée de prendre
une voie de séducteur des fois je parle
pas au lit tu parles pas les jamais une
fille qui t'a dit ils sont plusieurs
c'est peut-être un peu ce qu'elle
recherche chez moi est-ce que c'est pas
dur de venir avec tous ces personnages
qui publie les 100 personnages qui
habitent la tête
le hainaut mais j'avais bien compris
c'était au dessus de la ceinture
non parce que j'ai en fait je meurs
comme j'en ai beaucoup oui je m'en
débarrasse facilement
je parle de ceux des personnages donc
une fois que ce sera vraiment travail de
mercy est seul chez toi il arrive de
parler avec à haute voix avec la voix de
nous oui mais tu raconte ce que tu fais
par exemple un fou ce du pain café en
racontant comment tu te fais un
café-tabac de poivre d'arvor ou drucker
mais alors j'ai un site un sacré café
bien serré mais quand t'es fait chez
tutu prend facilement la boîte qui quand
je suis fâché je suis plutôt c'est ma
voix que j'utilise depuis que d'ailleurs
on ne reconnaît pas parce que je suis
pas souvent fâché avoir surpris
c'est aussi et donc non c'est un donc
génial de la nature que tu as parce que
d'abord ce rapport plein de blé ensuite
il fait rire les gens j'ai mis un
centime
essentiellement il a fallu 10 ans à 6 a
laissé encore été payés mais tu vas être
très très cher dis moi tu sais qu'il ya
un autre don de la nature que tu as
je suis sûr que tu ne sais pas tu sais
pas tu as 18 l'air c'est un don fouet à
ses yeux bleus s'est pas démenti non ça
pas de l'anti là non marc gardes nature